-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy Award-winning co-host of
"CBS Mornings,"
host of the SiriusXM show
"Gayle King in the House,"
and the editor at large of
"Oprah Daily."
The winter issue of
"O Quarterly," which features
this year's list of Oprah's
favorite things is on newsstands
now and available at
oprahdaily.com.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Gayle King,
everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back, Gayle.
-Hello, human beings.
I'm so glad to be here.
-It's nice to be in a room
with human beings, isn't it?
-It really is.
-I do not take it for granted
ever.
-Yes.
-Ever.
-Now more than ever.
-Ever, ever have.
-This must have been, you know,
an exciting month for you.
We've talked about our shared
affection and appreciation
for Taylor Swift.
-Yes.
-A big Taylor Swift month.
-She has a new tour coming out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She has a new tour coming out.
-Be honest.
When someone like her goes on
tour, do you have, like, an in
on tickets, or are you
on TicketM--
are you, like,
refreshing the link?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm refreshing the link.
-There you go. Thank you.
-No. I've been to all
of Taylor's concerts.
And last time I was here,
she was coming the day after,
and I was so bummed.
-Yeah.
-Because I've seen her
in concert several times.
And now the new -- the new
album, "Midnight at 3:00 a.m.,"
I got the deluxe version.
-Oh, look at you.
-Yep.
She's going to be in New York
the 26th, 27th, 28th,
but I'm not sure.
-Yeah.
-It's Memorial Day weekend.
-That's very exciting.
-Oh, I'm definitely going.
-A little creepy how much
you know it.
-Oh, I'm definitely going.
-Alright, good.
That's very exciting.
-She is such a great songwriter.
I really like her.
I like her music,
so I'm excited.
-Of course. We talked about
your grandson, Luca.
-Oh, yes.
-Just turned one.
Look at this dude.
-Look, he just turned one.
[ Audience aws ]
-Is he a Halloween minion
or is he an everyday minion?
-He was a minion, yes.
-He was a minion for Halloween.
-Yes. And let -- He's very close
in age to your favorite
daughter, Addie.
-Yeah.
-You only have one daughter.
-Yeah, we have one.
She is my favorite.
-He was born on the 13th.
-She was born on the 15th.
-Yes, so that's why I always
remember that.
-And I want to ask a question
because the last time
you were here, we talked
about -- you know,
it's a very high-stakes
operation when you decide what
your grandchildren are going
to call you as a grandparent.
-And Seth threw shade, guys.
-Yeah.
-He threw shade.
-'Cause you wanted --
Now, it should be noted, I --
It is confirmed that I'm
on Oprah's side here.
-Yes.
-Oprah also threw shade.
-Yes, yes, yes. Yeah.
-That you wanted to be called
"Gaya."
-I ignore her shade.
And her shade is private.
Your shade was in front of
all of the studio audience.
[ Laughter ]
And that night when I got home,
people go,
"Well, maybe he has a point."
-Yeah.
-I did say I wanted to be called
"Gaya" because it kind of sounds
like Gayle.
-Uh-uh.
-And it means "mother Earth."
And Seth said, "If you have
to explain a grandma name,
that's probably not
a good idea."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So we're a year in.
What does Luca call you?
-Well, he's not really
speaking yet,
so I'm going to leave it up
to him.
But I've come up with
another name.
"Gan-Gan."
-"Gan-Gan?"
[ Audience aws ]
-Isn't that nice? Gan-Gan?
[ Applause ]
-You're all missing the point.
-Seth, I think that's --
-It's up to Luca.
-I know.
-Just wait.
-Yeah, but don't you want to
just sort of guide him along?
I don't want him
to call me Gayle.
Ellen DeGeneres said he can just
call you, "Hey, Miss Lady."
I don't like that.
-Yeah. No. That's true.
-I want something that's
friendly and cute.
-Gan-Gan's not the worst.
It's better than Gaya. Yeah.
-See, I thought Gaya was nice,
but now you have me
rethinking myself.
-I'm sorry that I --
-I don't like doubting myself.
-I'm being a real bully
about this, and I apologize.
So more importantly,
midterms are tomorrow.
-Yes.
-What's your day like?
Obviously, stakes are very high.
You're in the news business.
-Stakes are very high.
-I do feel like maybe your
Wednesday morning will be more,
I mean, tomorrow when you're
on in the morning,
certainly, you won't have much
to say other than the fact
that people are going to
the polls.
-It's going to be
a very long day.
And also, when I was coming
here, in the elevator,
somebody on your team said,
"Seth gives us a day off
so we can vote."
So, bravo to you.
-Yeah.
-I think that's great.
It's great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No, that is --
-No. No, no, seriously.
-It's not -- it's --
-Seriously, Seth --
-I have to stop you.
It's not true.
-No, it is true.
-No, it's not true.
Yes, they have the day off,
and I hope they all vote.
But NBC was like,
"We want to put the news on."
-No. They said it was Seth.
[ Laughter ]
-No, they did -- I just don't
want to be out here being like,
"I went into NBC and I was like,
'You listen to me.'"
And they're like,
"Why are you here?"
-Okay.
Well, your team has the day off
and the woman told me
that she's going to be voting.
And I just thought
that was very cool.
-I certainly hope they all vote.
-Yes, I do too.
-And if they don't show me
the sticker,
they go into the penalty box.
[ Laughter ]
-I do too. I do too.
I can't wait to vote,
but I'm very nervous.
It's going to be a long day.
-When you cover it --
-It's going to be
a long, long day.
-You know what?
I do, again, I think like --
Even on Wednesday morning,
there's a real likelihood that
a lot of these bigger elections
are going to be
so close to call.
-That's true.
-And we do live in an era now
where I feel like conspiracy
theorists often reflect
back to the first thing
that is said about the results
from people
in the news business.
-Yeah, people are
highly suspicious.
-So, how do you speak about it?
-They're very suspicious.
And listen, by the end of
the day tomorrow, there will be
several races
that you don't know.
Last time, the last election,
we were on the air --
I didn't even get to go home.
I ended up wearing the same
dress that I started out
in the morning, when we started,
to the next day
because the races went so long.
This time, I think they're going
to break it up a little bit.
But we may still not know.
And just because you don't know
doesn't mean
there's something wrong
with the process.
But it's so scary to me, Seth,
because people are so --
they're so doubtful.
There's such mistrust
that it's frightening to me.
-It is a very frightening time.
-Yes.
-I was looking at
your monologue.
-We're going to have to face it
no matter what, but I think one
of the nice things is
there are the holidays coming.
They are Oprah's favorite thing.
-Yeah.
-We're going to talk about it in
our next act,
but I wanted to start with
a ritual to kick it off.
-Yes, yes, yes.
-I have some chai tea,
which I know this is --
-That's her favorite. Yes.
-This is an Oprah staple.
And I'm going to pour us
some chai tea.
And what do you -- You have
some affirmations for us?
-Okay, now this is good. This is
on her favorite things list.
I like this.
-Okay.
-And, Seth, we're going to do
this together.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-Because what do you do,
Seth Meyers, to center yourself?
-What do I do to center myself?
-Yes. What do you do?
-I don't feel particularly
centered if I'm being honest.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
May I have a suggestion for you?
-Yes. Great.
-This is "The Life You Want"
daily inspiration cards.
Oprah is really, guys,
a quote a minute.
She's very good.
-Yeah.
-So, we have Oprah
and other thought leaders.
And so every day there are
365 cards in this box.
-Okay. That's one for every day.
-Yeah, one for every day.
[ Laughter ]
So, she takes a card.
She reads a card while she's
sipping her chai tea.
-So, she reads a quote that she
of -- one of her quotes?
[ Laughter ]
-No, no. This is for you.
-Oh, this is for me.
-This is for you.
-But should I give 365 quotes
for Oprah?
-For her, she's just
sipping the chai.
-Oh, I see.
-For you.
-For me, it's like I have her
there with me sipping.
-Yes. Yes, yes.
-Okay.
-Yeah, you can feel
her presence.
So, one of the cards says this.
Very appropriate the night
before election.
"Transformation doesn't happen
unless you're willing.
It's your choice."
-Mm.
-So that's on the front
of the card.
Then the back,
something to think about.
Then she has, you know,
breathing exercises,
meditative things.
I like that.
-Okay. Great.
-Would you like to pick a card?
-I would love to pick a card.
-Pick a card, any card.
-Okay, I feel like
you forced that card.
[ Laughter ]
-No, I didn't.
I have three to choose from.
-Okay, ready?
-Yes.
-Gaya is a perfectly appropriate
name.
[ Laughter and applause ]
No, that's not it.
-Don't try to clean it up.
-Alright, so I start here.
This is an Oprah quote.
"Your life is always
speaking to you.
The fundamental question is,
'Will you listen?'"
Mm, chai.
-How about that?
[ Laughter ]
Okay, I'll take another sip.
-And then something
to think about.
We all have that little voice
inside of us.
That feeling...
-That is true.
-...deep in your gut that's
always there to give you --
By the way, at this point
in the card,
my kids are already screaming.
[ Laughter ]
And I'll be like, "You be quiet!
Oprah is communicating with me
via card!"
[ Laughter ]
What is whispering to you
right now?
-But these are 365 days that you
can pick something.
-It's lovely.
-It's just something --
I do think it's lovely. I do.
-Give me one more.
I feel like you're --
-This is my last one.
This is my last one.
"Everything you do and say shows
the world who you are."
I know that's true.
-Mm-hmm.
-So who are you, Seth Meyers?
-Who am I?
-Who are you?
-I'm someone who's regretting
how hard
I've been on you
about this name.
-No, you don't care.
-I don't care at all.
-I know you don't care.
I know you don't.
[ Laughter ]
-Now we're going to do
some real -- some more.
This is just one of many.
-Oh, I did bring some more
favorites for you.
But this is something
that's on the list.
-Alright. That's on the list.
And we're going to see a bunch
more things on the list.
We'll be right back with
more from Gayle King.